Normand Grondin.
- Santiago, 5 ans, s'est
présenté le printemps dernier
à l'Hôpital de Montréal pour
enfants avec un grave problème
d'épilepsie causé par
une maladie rare, la sclérose
tubéreuse.
L'équipe médicale propose
aux parents de réaliser
une intervention chirurgicale
de pointe.
Ils acceptent.
Le neurochirurgien Jean-Pierre
Farmer est le médecin traitant
du petit garçon.
Dr JEAN-PIERRE FARMER,
chirurgien, Hôpital de Montréal
- Il avait environ 200 crises
du côté gauche par jour, que
les parents ne voyaient pas,
pendant la nuit par exemple,
et tout ça. Donc des crises
sous cliniques, mais qui
affectent le fonctionnement
du cerveau.
Ça, c'est notre carte de
ce qu'on doit enlever.
- La sclérose tubéreuse cause
la formation de petites masses
non cancéreuses un peu partout
dans le corps de ceux qui en
sont atteints. Dans le cerveau
de Santiago, il y en avait
une cinquantaine.
- C'est du cerveau, mais
c'est du cerveau qui est très
désorganisé. Les neurones sont
très désorganisés.
- Le défi : identifier parmi
toutes ces lésions lesquelles
étaient responsables des crises
d'épilepsie.
Dr ROY DUDLEY, chirurgien,
Hôpital de Montréal pour enfants
- Ça, c'est un patient,
avec les plans des trajectoiress
avant la chirurgie.
- Pour y parvenir, on a d'abord
réalisé une cartographie
du cerveau de l'enfant.
Puis on a utilisé ce robot tout
neuf, équipé d'un bras mobile.
Partout dans le monde,
des experts en chirurgie y ont
recours pour leurs interventions
de haute précision. Dans ce
cas-ci, il a permis d'introduire
une vingtaine d'électrodes dans
une zone prédéterminée du crâne
de Santiago.
- On a besoin d'une idée,
parce que ce n'est pas possible
de mettre des électrodes
dans toutes les places
dans le cerveau.
- Le robot est d'une efficacité
redoutable. Équipé d'un GPS,
il permet d'insérer chaque
électrode au mile près,
sans ouvrir la boîte crânienne,
en minimisant la douleur du
patient et les risques
d'endommager le cerveau.
- Il y a des risques aussi,
mais si on utilise les images de
vaisseaux avant et qu'on netouce
risque est très, très, très bas.
- En tout, l'intervention aura
duré à peine deux heures.
Dans le passé, la même
intervention aurait exigé
presque 10 fois plus de temps.
Santiago a ensuite passé
3 jours au lit, branché surun mt
son problème, il a été opéré
à deux reprises et aujourd'hui,
ce n'est plus le même enfant.
Pour son médecin,
c'est également une victoire
considérable sur une maladie
très handicapante.
- Quand on dit qu'il faisait
200 crises d'un côté par jour
et peut-être deux ou trois de
l'autre côté, puis qu'il n'en a
pas fait depuis, c'est déjà
énorme. C'est sûr que six mois,,
mais on est juste au début de
sa nouvelle vie, si vous voulez.
- Ici Normand Grondin,
Radio-Canada, M